E
PRIVILEGES SUSTAINED.
AND SHE ALSO SAID NONE OF THE
CLAIMS OF HAVING HIS RIGHTS
HIGHLIGHT HAVE BORNE OUT IN THE
RECORD.
>> ELIE, YOU WROTE THE BOOK ON
BILL BARR.
AND THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
SPECIAL MASTER REVIEWING
DOCUMENTS OF THE MAR-A-LAGO
SEARCH.
HE DOESN'T GO ALONG WITH JOHN
SALE, THIS IS WHAT HE SAYS.
>> THE OPINION, I THINK, WAS
WRONG.
AND I THINK THE GOVERNMENT
SHOULD APPEAL IT.
IT IS DEEPLY FLAWED IN A NUMBER
OF WAYS.
I DO NOT THINK THE APPOINTMENT
OF A SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING TO
HOLD UP.
AND EVEN IF IT DOES, I DO NOT
SEE IT FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGING
THE TRAJECTORY.
IN OTHER WORDS, I DO NOT THINK
IT CHANGES THE BALL GAME SO
MUCH AS WE WILL HAVE A RAIN
DELAY FOR A COUPLE OF INNINGS.
>> WELL, I MEAN, PARTIALLY HE
AGREES WITH WHAT JON SAID, A
RAIN DELAY IN FOR A COUPLE OF
INNINGS.
BUT HE DOES NOT THINK SHE GOT
IT RIGHT.
WHAT IS YOUR REACTION TO THESE
COMMENTS AND WHAT IS AT STAKE
HERE?
>> WELL, I CERTAINLY AGREE WITH
BOTH JON AND BILL BARR THAT
THIS IS A DELAY, THIS IS A
HOLDOUT, THIS IS NOT GOING TO
DETERMINE ANY OUTCOMES OF THE
CASE.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER THE JUDGE
GOT IT RIGHT OR WRONG, LET ME
JUST SAY THIS, BE WARY OF ANY
BLANKET ASSERTIONS THAT THE
JUDGE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT OR
ABSOLUTELY WRONG ON EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
BECAUSE THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS, WE HAVE VERY LITTLE CASE
LAW TO EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
AND YOU WILL HEAR PEOPLE FROM
TIME TO TIME MAKE ASSERTIONS
LIKE A FORMER PRESIDENT DOES
NOT HAVE A CANNOT INVOKE
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE.
THAT IS JUST NOT RIGHT.
THE SUPREME COURT HAS SAID
THERE CAN BE NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES WERE A FORMER
PRESIDENT CAN INVOKE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF DECISION
THAT IS INVESTED IN OUR
DISTRICT COURT JUDGES, A TRIAL
COURT JUDGES.
I THINK WHAT THIS JUDGE DID IS
WEIGH TWO COMPETING FACTORS.
ON ONE HAND, NOT WANTING TO
SLOW DOWN OR CREATE UNNECESSARY
BURDEN.
ON THE OTHER HAND, AS JON SAID,
LET'S BE SAFE, LET'S BRING IN A
THIRD PARTY, LET'S BRING IN A
NEUTRAL OUTSIDER, SO AT A
MINIMUM WE WILL HAVE AN
APPEARANCE HERE, WE CAN TELL
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT ALL
PRECAUTIONS WERE TAKEN TO GUARD
THE PRIVILEGES.
AND I THINK THE JUDGE DID A
REASONABLE JOB OF BALANCING
THOSE TWO FACTORS.
>> LISTEN, THE COUPLE TIMES WE
HEARD FROM THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL BILL BARR, HE HAS BEEN
GOING AGAINST WHAT, YOU KNOW,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT, ABBY, HE
WAS ONE THE PRESIDENTS BIGGEST
ENABLERS, BUT NOW IS MAKING A
HARD TURN.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID TO THE
JANUARY 6TH SELECT COMMITTEE,
WATCH THIS.
>> I MADE IT CLEAR I DID NOT
AGREE WITH THE IDEA OF SAYING
THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND
PUTTING OUT THIS STUFF, WHICH I
CALL THE PRESIDENT WAS BULLISH
IT.
IF HE REALLY BELIEVES THE STUFF,
HE HAS, YOU KNOW, LOST CONTACT
WITH, HE'S BECOME DETACHED FROM
REALITY IF HE REALLY BELIEVES
THE STUFF.
THERE WAS NEVER AN INDICATION
OF INTEREST IN WHAT THE ACTUAL
FACTS WERE.
>> HE IS PARTIAL TO A CERTAIN
WORD, ABBY, BECAUSE HE'S
CALLING TRUMP'S REQUEST FOR A
SPECIAL MASTER A CROCK OF DISH.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THE SEND?
>> YOU KNOW, BILL BARR IS SUCH
AN INTERESTING CHARACTER IN ALL
OF THIS.
I THINK BASED ON HIS TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE, IT IS PRETTY CLEAR
THAT HE THOUGHT THAT SOMETHING
CHANGED WITH TRUMP IN THOSE
LAST MONTHS OF HIS PRESIDENCY,
WHERE HE BECAME DETACHED FROM
REALITY, HE STOP LISTENING TO
THE PEOPLE AROUND HIM, SO MANY
CABINET OFFICIALS LIKE BARR PUT
UP WITH A LOT OF BEHAVIOR FROM
TRUMP THAT THEY PERSONALLY DID
NOT LIKE BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT
THAT TRUMP WAS STILL LISTENING
TO THE COOLER HEADS, THE
RATIONAL HEADS.
AND THAT CHANGE FOR BARR TOWARD
THE END.
AND SO, I AM NOT SURPRISED TO
SEE THAT HE THINKS THIS IS ALSO
A BIT OF A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
I'M INTERESTED IN HOW EVER JUST
THE FACT THAT BARR WAS SORT OF
KNOWN AS ATTORNEY GENERAL AS
SOMEONE WHO HAD A VERY STRONG
BELIEF IN, YOU KNOW, THE POWER
OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH, THE
POWER OF THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
AND NOW, HE SEEMS TO BE SAYING
THAT, YOU KNOW, TRUMP REALLY
DOES NOT HAVE A VALID EXECUTIVE
CLAIM.
PERHAPS THIS IS ALL JUST
BECAUSE OF THE BITTER TASTE
LEFT IN HIS MOUTH AFTER ALL
THAT TRUMP HAS SAID ABOUT HIM,
AND THE WAY THAT HE DEPARTED
ADMINISTRATION.
BUT BARR HAS HAD A BIT OF A
SHIFT HERE WHEN IT COMES TO
TRUMP.
AND IT IS ALSO A REFLECTION OF
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO LEFT
THAT ADMINISTRATION AT THE END
FELT ABOUT TRUMP.
THEY STAYED FOR A LOT OF THAT
PRESIDENCY UNTIL THE END.
AND THEY ARE IN THAT CLUB OF
PEOPLE WHO THINK THAT PERHAPS
TRUMP SHOULD NOT BE ANYWHERE
NEAR THE PRESIDENCY.
ALTHOUGH WE SHOULD BE CLEAR,
DON, BILL BARR HAS KIND OF
DANCED AROUND THIS ISSUE OF
WHETHER HE WOULD VOTE FOR TRUMP
AGAIN.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE KIND
OF HAD IT WITH THESE
CANDIDATES.
>> ELIE, I WANT YOU TO WEIGH IN,
BECAUSE THE LAST COUPLE TIMES
WE HEARD ABOUT IT, IT HAS NOT
BEEN PRO TRUMP.
THIS IS A GUY WHO SPUN THE
MUELLER REPORT IN FAVOR TRUMP.
AGAIN, YOU WROTE THE BOOK.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE?
>> YEAH, I HAVE GIVEN UP TRYING
TO PSYCHOANALYZE BILL BARR.
I THINK ABBY HIT THE NAIL ON
THE HEAD THERE.
THIS IS A PERSON, LET'S NOT
FORGET, DESPITE WHAT HE'S DONE
OVER THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS, HE
SPENT TWO YEARS LYING TO US,
LYING TO CONGRESS, LYING TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC.
TRYING TO GET TRUMP OUT OF
TROUBLE, DESTROYING THE FACTS,
DESTROYING THE LAW, SPREADING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
HE WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PROPONENTS OF THE ELECTION
FRAUD THEORY IN THE MONTHS
LEADING UP TO THE ELECTION.
NOW, AS ABBY SAID, HE HAD A
CERTAIN POINT.
I GUESS EVERYBODY HAS GOT THEIR
BREAKING POINT WHERE HE SAID
I'M WILLING TO GO THIS FAR, I'M
WILLING TO BEND THE TRUTH THIS
FAR, BY A CERTAIN POINT, I
THINK BILL BARR REALIZE IT WAS
OVER.
THE ELECTION WAS OVER.
DONALD TRUMP WAS OUT, HE WAS
OUT.
AND I THINK BILL BARR MADE A
MOVE THAT AT A MINIMUM WAS
DESIGNED TO SERVE HIS OWN SELF
INTEREST, IS RATIONAL SELF
INTEREST, SAYING I NEED TO MAKE
A BREAK, I WON'T USE HIS
LANGUAGE, BUT BS, BS.
AND WE'RE SEEING THAT EVEN NOW
ON HIS COMMENT ON THE SPECIAL
MASTER.
>> MR. SALE, THERE IS A FRIDAY
DEADLINE FOR A JOINT FILING ON
THE SPECIAL MASTER.
BUT THESE TWO SIDES HAVE NOT
AGREED ON MUCH, SO HOW IS THIS
GOING TO WORK?
>> WELL, I DO NOT THINK THERE
DON'T AGREE ON ANYTHING.
A JUDGE WILL HAVE A CANDIDATE
IN MIND, AND HOPEFULLY, IT WILL
BE A CANDIDATE OF SUCH STATURE
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
HAVE FAITH IN THE REVIEW AND
FAITH IN THE JUDICIARY.
YOU KNOW, I KNOW THAT THIS
JUDGE HAS TAKEN A LOT OF
CRITICISM IN THE LAST FEW DAYS.
I GENERALLY BELIEVE WHAT THE
CHIEF JUSTICE, SAID THERE ARE
NO OBAMA JUDGES, AND THERE ARE
NO TRUMP JUDGES.
ONCE JUDGES TAKE THAT OATH, I
THINK THEY CALL AS THEY SEE IT.
I THINK JUDGE CANNON HAS DONE.
THIS >> YOU DON'T THINK, LISTEN,
MAYBE THAT'S RIGHT.
BUT YOU DON'T THINK THAT MAYBE
THEY WERE JUDGE SHOPPING,
CONSIDERING THAT THEY ENDED UP
WITH THIS PARTICULAR JUDGE, IN
THIS PARTICULAR JURISDICTION?
>> I KNOW THAT HAS BEEN SAID.
THEY DID NOT CHOOSE TO
INTERVENE BEFORE JUDGE REINHART
IN THE SEARCH WARRANT MATTER.
BUT THIS CASE WENT, WAS FILED
IN WEST PALM BEACH, NOT A FORT
PIERCE.
AND IT WENT INTO THE WHEEL AND.